the u.s has passed another grim
milestone in its battle with the
coronavirus there are now more than 7
million known infections in this country
with more than 55
000 new cases reported on friday that
is pushing the death toll to more than
203
thousand people in this country the
centers for disease control and
prevention warns
90 percent of the population remains
vulnerable
but change is in the air florida's
governor is lifting all restrictions on
bars restaurants and
other businesses and here in new york
outdoor dining will become
permanent michael george has more this
morning good morning michael
michelle good morning outdoor tents and
sidewalk seating
will now become a permanent fixture
across new york city
the announcement by mayor bill de blasio
has restaurant owners breathing a sigh
of relief but
there are also some clear signs this
pandemic is far from
over as new york restaurants reopen
there are some cold hard facts coming
out too
u.s cases rose 10 percent over the last
few weeks
according to the department of health
and human services an average of
43 000 new cases each day
people of color continue to be hit
hardest and so are their children
in terms of disparities that we see in
adults
is being seen in children but in florida
it's come one come all for the
republican governor
we're not closing anything going forward
we're going to be able to host the super
bowl in february
and that leaves health professionals
there concerned
it's not based on science it's the kind
of politics that's
going to backfire already at least eight
states are reporting spikes in new cases
of the coronavirus
showing an increase of more than 60
percent in the past two weeks
in wisconsin the caseload rose nearly
100 percent
i have extended the public health
emergency in our state for an additional
30 days
new jersey's governor phil murphy is
sticking with restrictions
as is virginia's governor ralph northam
but he and the first lady report they've
tested positive for kovid and will now
isolate for 10 days
and in massachusetts the virus spread at
a veterans facility known as the
soldiers home
became a criminal matter we believe this
is the first
criminal case in the country brought
against those involved in nursing homes
during the coven 19 pandemic two
administrators are charged with
mixing sick patients with others who
didn't show symptoms
they risked their lives from the beaches
of normandy
to some the jungles of vietnam to know
that they died under the most horrific
circumstances is truly
shocking now all this happens
just a few weeks before the flu season
hits which has a lot of doctors fearful
that fighting the covet outbreak along
with a flu outbreak will [ __ ] the
health care system
that's why they say it's all the more
important that americans get their flu
shots as
early as possible dana all right michael
sound advice